a group of 37 state attorneys general
sent a letter to Facebook CEO Mark
Zuckerberg demanding answers about the
company's user protections the Federal
Trade Commission said yesterday it does
have substantial concerns over how
Cambridge analytic obtained users
information the FTC is now investigating
Facebook's privacy practices this
morning whistleblower Christopher Wiley
is testifying before British lawmakers
he exposed how more than 50 million
Facebook users data was leaked to
Cambridge analytical vladimir duthiers
our streaming network that CBS n is here
with the ongoing fallout flag good
morning good morning the story is not
going away we've been saying that all
week Facebook sent a letter to the House
of Commons saying Mark Zuckerberg will
not testify in front of British
lawmakers instead he will send a senior
representative the company has lost 73
billion dollars in values since earlier
this month and is besieged by
investigations lawsuits and hearings in
London and the United States there's a
lot of reasons why I find the company
problematic
Christopher Wiley the former director of
research for Cambridge analytic met with
British lawmakers to discuss the data
firm's operations it is categorically
untrue categorically untrue that
Cambridge analytics has never used
Facebook data in Washington the Federal
Trade Commission opened an investigation
into how that Facebook data ended up in
the hands of the British political
consultancy firm and whether it was
legal I think this is pretty cut-and-dry
the Sam Lester consumer privacy council
at the Electronic Privacy Information
Center says a 2011 consent order between
Facebook and the FTC prohibits data on
unsuspecting users from being harvested
and sent to Cambridge analytical this
whole mess could have been avoided if
the FTC had been doing its job and had
been enforcing this order it's very
serious with what Facebook has done on
Monday Republican Senate Judiciary
Chairman Chuck Grassley asked Facebook
CEO Mark Zuckerberg to testify before
his committee on April 10th a bipartisan
group of 37 state attorneys general also
sent Zuckerberg a letter with their
concerns while a state attorney in
Illinois filed a lawsuit accusing
Facebook of fraud and
their business practices I think there
is this expectation of privacy there is
this expectation of data protection that
we've seen in this particular case has
failed facebook says it remains strongly
committed to protecting privacy but the
company also confirmed that has been
compiling text and call logs of Android
phone users Facebook insists it only
does this for users who choose to sync
their contact list with certain social
apps interesting reaction from a lot of
I don't know about you if you're feeling
this but a lot of my friends on Facebook
some of them are actually saying we're
out we're leaving you know it's I don't
know it's not clear how big a wave that
is but it is happening one of the things
I talked about with Dan Ackerman from
Sina yesterday was why not just have a
opt-out button a kill switch essentially
so that you're not tracked at all
yeah and Dan said Facebook would go out
of business because everybody would
choose that option that's how they're
making money exactly right all right
glad Thanks